こんにちははじめ冊のです皆さん似顔絵書いてもらったことがあります
僕もたまにあるんですけどもあのみてください赤済車ちょうどいいです
最後にがあってそう可愛かったらなが笑顔になれるんですけども世の中にはそうでは
ないんでが多いもあるんですよ皆さん
胡蝶似顔絵ってわかりますか伍長に側でもその名の通りなんですけどもその人の顔の
特徴こっち
そうしてようやくして言うとその人なんか後部財布に見せる書き方例えばない日目が
小さい人だったらもっと目を小さくしたらいいなが顎が尖っている人だったらもっと顎
をとがらせるとか分の顔の特徴ってなんかコンプレックスになることが多いねほんとに
行くと誇張されるっていうなんかそんないい気分というかまぁなんかね嫌だと思うん
ですけどもあの後ちょっと一番入って
ました彼の顔の骨を願い私に帰ってみました
これがほらプチの突端またゾーンを交わさない
[音楽]
[笑い]
ブーブー言っ
入ってからこそにょちょいだったんですか
もう似顔絵て結局元のイラストがあるんですよ
元乗り出すと誇張させてに花を植えを作る
ってことはってことは元のイラストと祖母も誇張されていたらその似顔絵はさらにこと
をされるんじゃないかまず普通の顔の写真があります2顔の写真を誇張された二行4回
てもらうそのこそされた[ __ ]をさらに小潮差ててに顔よ帰ってまたにその後調査者に
顔横瀬に通うために来ず食べて帰ってまでにが迂回てもらうさんからこそはさせて2階
湖東三山に鯉こそささみが養蚕で小僧さらには4回てもらうこれを繰り返すと主張最強
にうp されてるんじゃないかという検証今日やっていきたいとおもいます
あの傷つく準備ができていますなんか僕んんまだ比較的なが特徴的な変わると思うん
ですよ
今回後に何がは良いさんに手伝っていただいて僕の事の顔を誇張されないラフとお一人
に書いてもらうそれ
小僧世帯がストーサーに2人目小僧させレイラ須藤さんに目黒先生れそういう2年を
醸造したイラストをご決めて感じでござん回僕のかを故障させて進化させたらどういう
顔になるのか見ていきたいとおもいます
[音楽]
上甲は見る乗りづらい面でまずどれぐでブースにされてるんですよねじゃあまず一人目
見ていきましょう
ac さんに書いてもらってるとかゲームだっで撮ってもらってるんで早速見ていき
ましょう
いただきましたよ
はいはいはい
すごいなこうやって言う言い出すと書ける人ってすごいよねハナー
ちょっと丸めですね服地名が湧く特徴的なので
名可愛いね可愛いですね
甘いワイワイ食べ方を知って捉えております
ピアスについていきます唇がちょっとやパン
あなっ
[音楽]
まぁまぁまぁまぁ美味いはない唇で倒れやっぱりなんか特徴的なのは
はいはいはいやはりは凄く嬉しいですねいいんじゃないですか大般若です綺麗にして
頂いてスルーする作るすごい
あああああ
こちらが第二段階の胡蝶似顔絵はじめ雪のです
そんな映画が全然やな気持ちなのになんだか嬉しいですねなんか目が来くりっとして
[音楽]
さっきにしたような花ちょっと大きいのかな俺詰めて外国ぽてっとしてるんでまぁ
しっかりと取っ靴を捉えて愛許容範囲の許せる誇張似顔絵だと思いますありがとう
ございますすばらしい
シャツ着で次はコミュラフトをさらに骨をしてもらいます始まりました
おっと最初から泉ヶ丘真相中うんちみたいだぞ大丈夫か大丈夫か区で輪郭が
さて
あれ誰あれちょっと待ってますっ
んえっ
どーしたどーしたどーすかあれ
そんな輪郭ですたくて僕動作どうしてどうしてどうしてました
あれ
[音楽]
なんかすごい
俺の人書く馬鹿にしてますねなんだからもう見上げる中盗人みたいなやつただ花が
すごい目立つになりましたねちょっと若干やっぱ年か
わーって感じにはなりました
うん次様にこれをさらに誇張してもらいます
三代目サードはいん
おい何か
芸術作品が何が人も彼を書き方じゃないような気もしますけどこれがまあ
イラストレーターを使うということで
似顔伊勢素晴らしい動き音と唇がすごい
なんだからディズニー館でできるディズニー感でできてると
あーちょっと待ってちょっと頭って凄いな画面の3割が唇ですけどなのだろうだろう
はいはいはいはいはい
[音楽]
ん
んおおおお
ああああああああ
シべムンってや好きだか3段階目で結構も極限ですねば間に下げているとしか思えない
けど素敵なイラストですねありがとうございます
が甘いよなんかパッと見ながらディズニーキャラクターフックンのかと思ったら全然俺
だった
唇花を強調したいっていうのがすごく伝わりますね顔のパターを唇と鼻ですねあすごい
なぁ技がはい今日までつけていただいた本当に素敵な安ありがとうございます
a
あと2段階があるんですよ俺遺族骨をしたらマジで取っちゃんっていう今のイラスト
さらに誇張してもらいますはいじゃあ4枚目です
まぁでもなんかはい掃除機みたいな形考えてるのエレファント短毛
待ってよ
まず背景から入るかさ
ちょっと待ってもねぇらくだちゃんもうあ
動いすごい大うーんヘビィボウガンみたいなちょっと尖らせてきましたねぼく
若干何か僕でてです猫あっあごが高まづらですねあなたみたいな感じをすごい言われ
てる
[音楽]
ブーバー止まっ何を書いてもう1コトぁ
んだ完成までちょっと見ないようにしてみます逆に皆さんがごゆっくりどうぞ
どうなるんだろう力になるからちょっと財布みるわ
[音楽]
サーモンできたかすらさっすが握ってるでしょ
見ます
あってうん
そうじゃねぇ1さんに空っぽっ
あーちょっと待ってちょっと待ってあこれさーあ
バッって俺さぁそんな唇
へんかなーなんかをでも目可愛いですね
ねこれまつげないんですよまつげ長いよと眉毛もちょっと太めなのもしっかり生かされ
てますし
般若でも若干天パでくれる
塗ってなっているのを再現されているのと那珂ちゃんとペア様こうパってある支援隊的
になんだよね
可愛らしくは作ってるんですけども唇やばいですねここまで人怖いです何かもう
比較的そんなブサイクでもない気がしますよねこういうモンスターがいても俺は何か
ちょっとかわいいねって思っちゃうくらいの感じでした
私の顔極端に共通すると
こんな顔になることが今回分かります
[音楽]
voodoo
ん
持っていた
ていた
た
とって
[音楽]